uh sky science correspondent thomas
moore joins us now to talk about those
comments that were made thomas put it
into some kind of perspective for us
because later on this hour we're going
to hear from and the person who
discovered omega omicron in south africa
who says that actually this is quite a
mild variant on evidence there based so
far so it's a bit of a confusing picture
at the moment
yeah i mean there's conflicting evidence
on that to be perfectly honest uh
hospital rates are going up in south
africa too although they do seem to be
less likely to need oxygen but i can
tell you about the growth rates here in
in the uk and they are accelerating so i
it used to be the case that uh cases
were doubling uh in number every four to
five days but dr harry's there said they
were doubling every 1.9 days it is an
eye-watering rate of growth and new data
released by the uk health security
agency has revealed hot spots around the
country now
nationally about 24
of uh all cases are suspected to be
omicron uh at the moment and these are
suspected this is based on pcr tests
there's a there's a little [ __ ] there
that they could they can uh look at the
distinguished omicron from a delta but
it's not confirmed is likely but not
confirmed so 24 percent of all pcr tests
in london uh sorry in the country were
uh omicron but
51.8 percent were omicron in london and
that means it's overtaken from delta in
just a few weeks absolutely
extraordinary but there are three other
hot spots around england the east the
south east and the northwest where rates
are between 21 and 27
and if those areas follow the same
growth curve in london there too omicron
will overtake uh delta as the dominant
strain within the next three to four
days
and the data also shows there are
another five suspected cases of omicron
in hospital that's in addition to the 10
confirmed cases that we've already heard
about from the health security agency